ils sont trois leurs entreprises
attirent l'attention de géants de
l'informatique que ce soit bill gates ou
à pau hulluch lab ne passe pas inaperçu
et le petit mammouth qui l'ont mis au
monde séduit des milliers de parents car
il apprend à leurs enfants
l'art des divisions et des mathématiques
ils ont créé ce live fraction un jeu
dans lequel il faut ouvrir la voie à un
mammouth et pour y arriver il faut
apprendre à maîtriser les fractions pour
faire fondre les blocs de glace il faut
diviser adéquatement les blocs de lave
ça amène les enfants à se dire comment
je peux divisé mon blocs de lave en
quatre parties égales
donc on va te couper ici en deux ça
c'est une manière de faire
4/4